.
BUT EVIL EXISTS AND WE ARE
WATCHING IT UNFOLD IN YOUR
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH YOU BECAUSE
OF THE CONNECTICUT REPUBLICANS
ON CAPITOL HILL ARE DEMANDING
JOE BIDEN DO MORE TO CRIPPLE
PUTIN.
THIS IS MORE THAN A WAR.
THIS IS DENNIS EDWARD TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THIS IS NOT A WAR.
THIS IS A GENOCIDE OF THAT
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE BY A CRAZY MAN.
I HAVE MY GRANDMA.
SHE IS 95.
SHE IS IN THE CITY OF -- AND
THEY CAME INTO THE VILLAGE WITH
HEAVY MACHINE GUNS.
THEY KILLED ALMOST EVERY PERSON
IN THAT VILLAGE AND THEY KILL
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
BOMBS.
I MEAN, THEY ARE USING ILLEGAL
WEAPONS AND I CAN TELL YOU ONE
THING, IF WE DON'T STOP HIM
THERE, HE IS NOT GOING TO STOP.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN, ARE YOU
LISTENING?
WE CERTAINLY DIDN'T SEE THAT
PERSON.
WE DID NOT SEE THAT PASSION FROM
BIDEN LAST NIGHT.
HERE NOW IS CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
INDIANA'S FIFTH DISTRICT,
VICTORIA SPARTZ IS WITH US.
YOU WERE BORN IN UKRAINE.
I'M SURE YOU STILL HAVE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS THERE.
YOU ARE WATCHING ALL OF THIS
UNFOLD.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT JOE BIDEN'S
ECONOMIC ENERGY POLICIES PUSHED
EUROPE RIGHT INTO THE HANDS OF
LATIMER PUTIN AND THEY BECAME
DEPENDENT ON GAS AND OIL AND I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THE AMERICA
IMPORTING ENERGY, OIL,
157,000 BARRELS A DAY FROM
RUSSIA ALONE, AND EUROPE SO
DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA FOR THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THEIR ECONOMY.
IF THAT IS A BIG FACTOR IN ALL
OF THIS, IS THERE A SHORT-TERM
SOLUTION TO PUT OFF THE MONEY
SUPPLY TO LET ME PUTIN?
>> Congresswoman Spartz: THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME.
NO DOUBT ENERGY SECURITY IS
NUMBER ONE.
SECURITY ISSUES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE TOO
MANY PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN --
HOPEFULLY THEY CHANGE THE
PROVIDE THE BIGGER THREAT IS THE
CLIMATE CHANGE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
WE HAVE MUCH BIGGER PROBLEMS
RIGHT NOW AND A HALF LACK OF
COMMON SENSE.
WE HAVE LACK OF COMMON SENSE IN
EUROPE.
WE ALSO HAVE LACK OF COMMON
SENSE IN OUR COUNTRY.
CREATED A STABILITY INSTABILITY,
BLOODSHED AND A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
SO WE NEED TO BE SMART AND I
THINK THAT YOU LOOK AT THIS
PRESIDENT NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND IF
WE WANT TO TIP THE SCALE AND THE
PRESIDENT LISTENS TO THE S-CURVE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO IT
IS STOP FINANCING HIS WORK
BECAUSE -- I TOLD THEM, I'M VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU.
THEY SAID, VICTORIA, YOU
IMPORTED A LOT OF OIL, TOO.
AND I DID NOT HAVE AN ANSWER
BECAUSE IT WAS TRUE.
IT IS A DISGRACE THAT WE ARE
DOING THAT.
>> Sean: VIKTORIYA LET ME ASK
YOU THIS QUESTION.
WE ARE TOLD THAT PUTIN SENT IN
FOR HUNDRED MERCENARIES WITH THE
GOAL OF KILLING THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, ZELENSKIY.
NOT THE QUESTION IS, ONE REPORT
SAYS THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
THAT TIPPED OFF ZELENSKYY OF
WHAT DOUBLE OPERATION WAS ALL
ABOUT AND MAY HAVE EVEN SAVED
HIS LIFE.
YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
RUSSIANS THAT ARE WILLING TO
STEP UP AND STAND OUT AGAINST
VLADIMIR PUTIN, NOT WANTING TO
BE A PART OF A MODERN-DAY MASS
SLAUGHTER?
>> Congresswoman Spartz: I
THINK THERE IS ANOTHER PROBLEM,
YOU KNOW?
USED TO BE WE ALWAYS HAD
BANDITS, I ACTUALLY GREW UP IN
THE SOVIET UNION.
BUT THEY WERE NOT PART OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
NOW PRESENT PUTIN MADE CHECHNYA
MAFIA.
AND THREATENED RUSSIA.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE EVEN IN
HIS POLICE FORCE DO NOT LIKE
THAT BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE
LAWLESS AND HE IS USING THEM TO
SUPPRESS RUSSIAN PEOPLE AND
EVERYONE ELSE.
I WILL NOT BE SURPRISED IN THE
POLICE FORCE AND HIS PEOPLE, AND
THE TOOLS HE IS USING.
AND THAT WAS WHAT HE WAS USING
IN YOU CAN.
A FORMER CRIMINAL TO GET AROUND
THIS COUNTRY WITH A CRIMINAL
WAY.
AND THE UKRAINIANS SAID, NO,
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THEY TOOK HIM DOWN.
HE SENDS POLICE FORCES.
THEY KILLED 100 PEOPLE.
GUESS WHAT.
MILLIONS SHOT NEXT DAY.
NOW HE SENDS AN ARMY BECAUSE HE
WANTS TO TEACH THEM A LESSON AND
DESTROYED THEM BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT BE SUPPRESSED.
BUT I THINK HE UNDERSTOOD --
UNDERESTIMATES THAT UKRAINIANS.
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FIGHT.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO WIN.
>> Sean: IF PUTIN IS THE ONE
RESPONSIBLE, EVERY DEAD MAN
WOMAN AND CHILD IN YOUR FORMER
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE, THE BLOOD IS
ON HIS HANDS AND IF SOMEBODY IS
ABLE AROUND HIM AND HIS INNER
CIRCLE TO TAKE HIM OUT, BY
WHATEVER MEANS NECESSARY, IT
DOES NOT MATTER TO ME.
IF THEY ARE ABLE TO, WOULDN'T
THAT SENATE MESSAGE TO EVERY TWO
BIT WANNABE DICTATOR IN THE
WORLD THAT YOU ARE NEXT IF YOU
HAVE TO RESORT TO TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS AS VLADIMIR PUTIN
DOES?
>> Congresswoman Spartz: I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THAT THREAT IS
ALWAYS LIKE THAT.
A LOT OF CHANGING REGIMES HAPPEN
LIKE THAT THROUGH HISTORY.
I THINK ANY DICTATOR ALWAYS --
>> Sean: YOU DON'T THINK A
DICTATOR WOULD THINK TWICE ABOUT
INVADING AN INNOCENT COUNTRY?
>> Congresswoman Spartz:
UNFORTUNATELY, -- THIS IS
IRRATIONAL AND THIS IS SAD WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
BUT YOU KNOW, WE ARE ALSO
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE DONE A
BETTER JOB DEALING WITH HIM MORE
PROACTIVELY AND NOT REACTIVELY
BECAUSE HE WAS VERY CLEAR AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER YEARS
AGO, HE WAS ON FOX NEWS AND HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT.
YOU ARE NOT TAKING IT SERIOUSLY.
BUT I'M NOT TRYING TO WITH MY
MONEY TO DEFEND.
I'M GOING TO GO ON OFFENSE AND
DEVELOPMENT -- AND I THINK THAT
WAS A CLEAR MESSAGE.
WE NEED TO TAKE PEOPLE LIKE THAT
SERIOUSLY.
WE NEED TO STOP THAT BLOODSHED
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING T